hace 20 años
todos encontramos una manera distinta
lugares distintos
pero en el mismo momento de nuestras
vidas serían cambiadas por siempre
el mundo en el mundo resonaba las
sirenas
y luego hubo silencio con las voces
perdidas que jamás serían escuchadas de
nuevo estas vidas siguen siendo
preciosas y apreciadas por nuestro país
no solo para todo el país sino para
muchos de ustedes hoy recordamos su
perdida compartimos su dolor
y honramos a los hombres y mujeres que
han amado por tanto tiempo que han amado
muy bien
para aquellos que son muy jóvenes para
recordar aquel día de septiembre es
difícil de escribir la mezcla de
sensaciones que experimentamos
hubo horror a la escala de la
destrucción a la par
y también hubo sorpresa por el coraje y
la valentía que requiero para
enfrentarlo wow sorpresa también por la
audacia de esta maldad y gratitud por la
decencia que se lo puso tras el
sacrificio de los equipos de emergencia
en el momento de ayuda mutua con los
extranjeros con los extraños y en la
solidaridad por la pena
las acciones del enemigo revelaron el
espíritu del pueblo
nosotros nos orgullo hicimos de nuestra
nación autoridad en estos recuerdos
los pasajeros y la tripulación del vuelo
93 deben tener un lugar aquí los blancos
se convirtieron en los equipos de
rescate ahora muchas personas que están
con vida tienen una gran deuda con
tantas gracias mostrada en este campo en
ese momento sería un gran error
idealizar la experiencia de estos
eventos terribles
todo lo que mucha gente pudo ver
inicialmente fue
bueno
la muerte todo lo que se pudo ver
inicialmente fue el sufrimiento todo lo
que se pude escuchar fue el silencio
terrible y aterrador hubo muchos que hay
muchos que todavía siguen luchando con
este dolor solitario que sigue atacando
los desde adentro y en esas horas
complicadas aprendimos otras lecciones
también vimos que los estadounidenses
fueron vulnerables pero no frágiles
que poseían un núcleo de fortaleza que
sobrevivía lo peor que la vida les tenía
y les podía dar
aprendimos que el coraje es más común de
lo que creemos
que aparece esplendorosamente frente a
la muerte
sentimos vivamente
cada hora con esos seres amados
entendimos que era
un regalo temporal
y entendimos que incluso los días más
largos terminan muchos hemos tratado de
hacer una pregunta en el sentido
espiritual a estas situaciones no hay
una explicación simple para la mezcla de
providencia y de voluntad humana que
establece la dirección de nuestras vidas
pero la calma puede venir de distintos
tipos de conocimientos
después de navegar por la oscuridad
mucho tiempo muchos han entendido
que realmente daban pasos hacia la
gracia como nació en nuestros ajustes
han sido profundos muchos
estadounidenses luchan por entender como
un enemigo nos a odiar ya con tanta
fortaleza las medidas de seguridad
incorporadas en nuestras vidas
son fuente de comodidad y recordatorios
de nuestra vulnerabilidad
y hemos visto cada vez más evidencia en
que los peligros a nuestros a nuestro
país no pueden o bien solamente a través
de las fronteras sino de la violencia
que se reúne en nuestro interior
hay muy poco en común entre la violencia
extremista afuera y adentro pero hay un
punto en el pluralismo en
el desdén por la vida humana de la
determinación por acabar con los
símbolos nacionales son hijos del mismo
espíritu venenoso y es nuestro deber
continuo confrontarlo
después del 9/11
millones de estadounidenses valientes se
hicieron voluntarios para servir las
fuerzas armadas
las medidas militares tomadas durante
los últimos 20 años para
atacar a los peligros desde su fuente
han llevado a grandes debates pero hay
algo que es muy claro
debemos asegurarle a todos los que
lucharon además recientes batallas
nuestra nación
déjenme hablarle directamente a los
veteranos y a la gente en un informe la
causa que ustedes perseguir la alcanza
que ustedes persiguieron es la causa más
noble que eeuu de ofrecer de ustedes
protegieron a sus compañeros ciudadanos
del peligro se defendieron las creencias
de su país
y trataron de vender los derechos de los
oprimidos ustedes han enfrentado han
encontrado a la esperanza en lugares
oscuros ustedes han sido una fuerza para
el bien en el mundo
nada puede manchar su honor o disminuir
sus logros a ustedes ya los borrosos
fallecidos los países está completamente
agradecido con ustedes por siempre
[Aplausos]
más
las semanas y meses después de los
ataques del 11 orgulloso me enorgulleció
dirigir a un pueblo resiliente fuerte y
unido cuando se trata de los eeuu de
américa
esos días parecen distantes de lo que
vivimos ahora
cada argumento resulta convirtiéndose en
un choque cultural en esos momentos hay
mucha de nuestra política que se ha
convertido en un llamado negativo al
dolor al resentimiento eso nos preocupa
como nación y como futuro y yo he venido
sin explicaciones y sin soluciones
solamente puedo decirles lo que he visto
en los días más difíciles estados unidos
vi a millones de personas
tomar la mano de su vecino incisivamente
y reunirse alrededor de la causa de uno
y otro
ese es el eeuu que yo conozco
[Aplausos]
en un momento en el que la negatividad
religiosa ha andado libre he visto a los
estadounidenses rechazar el prejuicio y
recibir a la gente musulmana esa es la
nación a la que conozco
en un momento en el que la tea abismo
puede despertar odio y violencia contra
de la gente percibida como extranjera
envía a los estadounidenses reformar su
estilo de vida para darles acogida a los
refugiados ya los migrantes ese es el
eeuu que conozco
en un momento en el que algunos vieron a
esta generación
como individualista y decadente visto a
los jóvenes recibir aceptar una ética
del servicio y ponerse a la altura de
las acciones no egoístas esa es la
nación que conozco
[Aplausos]
esto no es solamente no sabia
es la versión genuina de quienes somos
es lo que hemos sido y lo que podemos
ser una vez más
hace 20 años los terroristas eligieron
un grupo aleatorio de estadounidenses en
un vuelo rutinario
como daño colateral de una en un acto
espectacular de terrorismo los 33
pasajeros y 7 miembros de la tripulación
del cuerno 23
pudieron haber sido cualquier grupo de
ciudadanos elegidos
aleatoriamente y de cierta manera
ellos estuvieron ahí en nombre de todos
nosotros los terroristas descubrieron
pronto que un grupo aleatorio de
estadounidenses es un grupo excepcional
de personas
enfrentando una circunstancia imposible
reconfortaron a sus seres amados a
través del teléfono
se preparando para la acción y vencieron
el intento de maldad estos
estadounidenses fueron fuertes valientes
y se unieron de maneras que
sorprendieron a los terroristas pero
esto no debería sorprender a ninguno de
nosotros
esta es la nación que conocemos
[Aplausos]
y cuando sea que necesitamos o
necesitemos esperanza inspiración
podemos ver el cielo y recordarnos dios
los bendiga